on y va
alors comment ça va
alors ouais le 2 à midi est bien et puis
le soir alors avant la grève on voit
bien la variabilité glycémique notamment
durant toute la journée avec les
glycémies les plus basses et les
glycémies les plus hautes
avec après la greffe
la réduction de cette variabilité
glycémique qui est la zone grisée
[Musique]
donc on remercie beaucoup et
où sont mes petites
[Musique]
voilà et bien la semaine prochaine alors
vous descendez en bas déposez votre
petite feuille
[Musique]
voilà voilà et bien la semaine prochaine
alors vous descendez en bas déposez
votre petite
[Musique]
feuille
j'ai le sentiment de revivre oui tout à
fait depuis 3 semaines les résultats
sont très très rapides parce que parce
que j'ai une stabilité qui me permet
d'être beaucoup moins fatigué et
je fais également beaucoup moins de
malaise
c'est un amas de simulation
[Musique]
les résultats sont extrêmement
concluants puisque après trois semaines
de traitement la patiente à une
réduction de 50 % de ses besoins
d'insuline un diabète parfaitement
contrôlé une absence d'hypoglycémie mais
il faut savoir que ce que l'on attend de
la grève l'îlot pancréatique chez ses
patients dont je le rappelle ils sont en
échec thérapeutique de tout ce qui
existe c'est la restauration de la
stabilité glycémique la cerise sur le
gâteau c'est l'insuline indépendance